- Hey guys, it's Amy from Tasty UK.
And today I'm gonna be
trying the recipes of three
celebrities to decide who
makes the best avocado toast.
In this mornings lineup,
we have cosmetic queen, Kylie Jenner,
the real queen of America, Meghan Markle,
and since we're talking royalty,
the potty mouth prince
himself, Gordon Ramsay.
So who's gonna take the crown?
Let's find out.
So we're gonna kick off
with Kylie Jenner's recipe.
This one is relatively simple
and I am an avocado toast purist.
So you just slice your
two avocados in half.
I'm just gonna score across the flesh
to make it easier to come out.
So many people went to hospital
with avocado hand injuries
from removing the stone like that.
So to safely remove the avocado stone,
you place a tea towel in your hand,
pop the avocado in there,
and confidently, viola.
Kylie wants to show us that
she is a master of everything
and we've seen a lot of
her cooking on her socials.
She's done Frosted flakes French toast,
which I actually made.
And her French toast was banging.
I have high expectations for this.
So I'm gonna scoop out the avocado flesh
and give it a mash in this bowl.
So you know your avo is ripe
when you pick off the stem
and beneath that you see green.
Avocado toast was a huge
thing a few years ago.
Every cafe in East London worth its salt
has avo toast on the menu.
So this is looking really
nice and smooth now.
So we're ready to plate.
A great tip to stop your
avocado from browning,
if you're not quite ready to plate,
just pit a bit of cling wrap
on the surface of the avocado.
That way it cannot oxidize and go brown.
So I'm gonna go ahead
and spoon this avocado
onto this lovely piece of toast.
I'm gonna do a nice thick layer.
A nice drizzle of agave.
A sprinkle of chili.
And to finish, a bit of salt.
And that is it.
Wow.
So this looks glistening and gorgeous.
Look at that ratio of avo to bread.
That is perfect.
Mm.
I like it.
It's very interesting
to put something sweet
on an avocado toast,
which isn't typically
something I would go for,
but I think the salt and the chili
is a really good addition.
I don't think this is an everyday thing.
If you're looking for a
dessert avocado toast,
this is the way to go.
But like I said, I'm a purist.
On a scale of one to
five, five being the best,
I'm giving Kylie Jenner's
avocado toast a 2.5.
I don't hate it.
That's a wrap on Kylie's recipe.
Let's see how Meghan measures up.
I'm really excited about this one
because I think adding a
salty, cheesy feta-like element
is gonna really elevate this dish.
We're gonna slice our avo in half.
This recipe calls for one
avocado to two slices of toast.
So it's a little bit stingy,
but maybe it's gonna be good.
Again, with the avocado trick.
Hey.
We're gonna score this avo
just to make sure it's
easier to get out the skin.
I heard that Meghan is a keen cook
and it's actually how
she snagged a prince.
The story goes that Prince
Harry proposed to her
the day that she had
cooked her roast chicken.
I have not myself tried or
seen any of Meghan's recipes,
but I can tell she's
got a taste for spice.
She's going around adding spice
to the royal family's lives.
That's for sure.
So we're just gonna scoop these avos out.
We're gonna mash this avo
until it's nice and smooth.
So I've half mashed this and
now I'm gonna add a tablespoon
of feta and then give it a good mix.
I'm using vegan feta,
but you can really use any that you like.
I have high expectations for this one.
Salty, spicy, creamy.
What's not to love?
I don't think this looks
the most visually appealing,
but I think the flavor
is gonna pack a punch.
So now we're gonna add some lemon juice.
Lemon juice makes everything better.
I got it mostly in the bowl.
And now I've added the lemon
juice, this is ready to plate.
So for Meghan's recipe, we're
using multi-grain bread.
And this is a bit of me,
I love this kind of bread.
Pop this avocado on this bread.
The bread to guac ratio is
not indulgent enough for me.
It's gotta be 50 50.
This is flat.
I'm adding a little bit
more height and texture
with extra crumbles of feta.
Gonna add some chili flakes.
A bit of salt.
You can't have avo toast
that is unseasoned.
And a few pepitas for crunch.
And there we go, Meghan
Markle's avocado toast.
I'm trying to find an area
where there's some chunkiness
to this, and I know you
guys are gonna be mad,
but I'm gonna take a bite
out of the middle like this.
Mm.
There's a taste sensation.
You know I was mad about the
ratios, but it actually works.
And I think that's because of the feta.
You first get the creamy avocado layer.
And then you get these sort
of punches of salty cheese,
which is just delicious.
And then on top of all of that,
you have the sprinkle of chili flakes,
which just makes this perfect.
I got that all in one bite.
Well done Meghan.
I'm gonna give this avocado
toast a four out of five.
I know.
I'm just as surprised as you.
This does really work.
So well done.
So now the one that I am
the most excited about.
It is Chef Ramsay's avo toast.
This next one is the
most chef-y of them all.
There are more steps in it.
You actually have to do some cooking
rather than just assembly.
Let's see if it's worth it.
I'm gonna add some oil to
the pan and saute my chorizo.
I'm using vegan chorizo,
you can use any you like.
I'm gonna cook this until
the edges are nice and crisp.
And then we'll move on
to adding the onion.
I think part of the
appeal of avocado toast
is how quick and simple it is to make.
But you know what?
I like the effort that he's gone to.
He's put the Gordon Ramsay
spin on it and I'm into that.
Ooh.
So now the edges are
looking nice and crispy.
I'm gonna add the onion and
give that a little saute.
Mm.
I haven't personally tried
Gordon's vegan recipes.
I feel like he said
something mean about vegans.
And since then we've not been friends.
So now that onion is nice and sauteed.
We're gonna add the garlic.
Just cook it until we can smell it
because there's nothing more
unforgivable than burnt garlic.
Unforgivable.
That smells so good.
I'm gonna make a gap in
the pan to add my tomatoes.
Tomatoes.
(crew laughs)
We have one cup.
So I'm going to add them cut side down
to the center of the pan
to give them a nice sear.
This is the most elaborate
avocado toast I've ever seen.
I could only make this recipe
after my first cup of coffee.
But look, it looks like
some kind of child's art.
It's like a preschool painting.
The tomatoes are looking nice and sweaty.
We're just gonna wait until
they brown on the bottom
and then we'll deglaze the pan.
Everyone loves Gordon Ramsay in England.
Is that true?
I mean, I can't speak
for the whole of England,
but Gordon Ramsay's a pretty liked guy.
I love Gordon Ramsay's duets.
Gordon, if you're watching,
come at maybe with your duets on TikTok.
Check out my lasagna pie.
The tomatoes are looking nice and charred.
So I'm gonna deglaze the pan
with some vegetable stock.
The recipe calls for chicken stock,
but I'm using veggie today.
It smells super fragrant, paprika-y,
garlicky, meaty.
Smells meaty.
It's looking very sophisticated.
We've grown up, we've leveled up.
So this is nice and reduced
and it smells gorgeous and juicy.
We're gonna add splash of sherry vinegar.
Give it a good season with salt.
And mix it up.
A sprinkle of parley.
So this was quite a lot of work,
but it's looking interesting.
I'm curious to see how this
is all gonna come together.
So we've got new components,
there's a lot going on here.
So we're gonna take it step-by-step.
Don't worry, I got you.
First of all, top tip,
we're gonna slice a piece of garlic
and rub the garlic on a
freshly toasted piece of bread,
just to add oomph to the flavor.
So we're using country
bread for this recipe,
a personal favorite of mine,
as of today when I learned what it was.
Okay, so now it's finally avocado time.
So for this recipe,
I'm gonna slice the avocado
thinly and fan it out.
If you wanna find out how
to make an avocado rose,
I have a tutorial on my Instagram,
@AmyTasty, check it out.
I'm just gonna rub a bit
of olive oil over the top
of the avo just to make it nice and smooth
and as good looking as it can be.
And here we go with the slicing.
So half an avocado per piece of bread.
And just fan that out like so.
We're gonna season it with a bit of salt
and a squeeze of lemon.
Next, the piece de resistance
is the chorizo mixture.
So I'm just gonna spoon
this over each piece,
giving it a nice generous layer.
Mm, I love the tomatoes all smushed up.
Pleasantly surprised by
the aesthetics of this.
Dressing these leaves
with a bit of olive oil.
A touch of sherry vinegar.
And just a sprinkle of salt.
You know, I don't think I've
ever actually eaten avo toast
with lettuce, so this is quite uncommon.
I think this is kind
of getting far removed
from the essence that is avocado toast.
There's a lot going on here,
but what's most important
is how it tastes.
So let's add these leaves on
top, just for a bit of garnish,
bit of extra flavor, bit of extra crunch.
The final touches, we have
a sprinkle of parsley.
Finally, we have the manchego.
I'm using vegan cheese.
You can use whatever cheese you like.
This seems like an unnecessary step.
You've gone too far Gordon, but we'll see.
I mean, he is a culinary genius.
So the ratios are wild here.
This is different from the other
recipes because rather than
a guacamole, it's a sliced
avocado, which I like,
but then you've gone and
covered up those gorgeous slices
with all of these other elements.
The topping to bread ratio,
I'm a fan of because I like
a lot going on on the bread.
This is like lifting weights.
Gonna get some guns.
So let's give it a go.
Mm.
Yes Gordon.
That is good.
Each individual layer comes through.
I would make this again,
but I wouldn't call this avocado toast.
This is chorizo's album,
avocado's just featuring on it.
I feel like the avocado kind of gets lost.
I think maybe the manchego was
supposed to give it a bit of
a salty edge, but you really
get that just from the chorizo.
But this is a Sunday morning breakfast,
when you've got a bit more time
to put a bit more energy and love into it.
So it's gonna come as
no surprise to anybody
that the chef is gonna make
the best avocado toast.
I'm gonna give this a 4.5 out of five.
So congrats Gordon, you won.
I'd suggest you make Gordon's recipe,
if you're feeling fancy
and you've got a bit
more time on a Sunday.
But I'd go for Meghan's,
if I was just making an
everyday avocado toast,
because it's got that little
extra something special
without too much effort.
And if you're looking for something sweet,
sure, try Kylie's.
So that's it for me today.
If you have any other
celeb showdown ideas,
let us know in the comments.
Thanks for watching.
Bye.
(gentle music)